you guys right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into cold and flu
season this fall it's just one scoop in
a cup of water every day that's it and
no need for a million different pills or
supplements to look out for your health
with athletic greens you're absorbing 75
high quality vitamins minerals whole
food source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free one
year supply of immune supporting vitamin
d and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com
tuesday again that is athleticgreens.com
tuesday to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance you guys we love
liquid deaths new flavored seltzers
liquid death is available at your local
amazon target albertson safeway 7-eleven
or sprouts you can even rock liquid
death merch did you know that esther of
course i have some go to liquid death
dot com slash trash to get free shipping
on their crazy limited edition merchant
apparel that's liquiddeth.com
trash to get free shipping on limited
edition merchant apparel liquid death
death to plastic murder your thirst
zoc doc is a free app that shows you
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance and are available when
you need them go to zocdoc.com trash and
download the zocdoc app for free then
start your search for a top-rated doctor
today and many are available within 24
hours that's z-o-c-d-o-c dot com slash
trash zocdoc dot com slash trash hi
slugs i am coming on the road in
september i'll be in austin and then i'm
coming to phoenix
uh portland and seattle get tickets at
esther on ice.com and my new podcast my
solo podcast just launched and you can
find that everywhere
you listen to stuff it's called esther
privetsky my pleasure
so today's guest is from the south side
of chicago that's not true
that's not true
the east side yeah i'm from the east
side of chicago
i'm from the lake the lake no east side
i'm from about 35 miles in the middle of
lake michigan but you said no to
i'm from the near north side
we you're from the north side dude
you're from like
where the quote-unquote dude are we
allowed to say jews jews yeah can we say
that on the spot yes you're from where
those people are from that's what we
call it the jews went north north i'm
like still
low north you're not as far up as them
yeah because you weren't you guys didn't
have any money no right but isn't worse
isn't skokie where like the holocaust
museum is yeah so skokie was the
original jew spot but then all the jews
got money and they moved to like the
nicer places and they left you guys
behind yeah and they left the museum
there
yeah they did it
dude that's so funny they're like leave
it in the poor neighborhood we're not
gonna we don't wanna see the property
taxes are lower in skokie where i'm from
because we have the really nice mall so
maybe that's why the holocaust museum is
there because there's low property taxes
very jewish stuff yeah but so you're
from north the near north side actually
oh okay when i was a kid i was raised
downtown
okay and so funny on my wikipedia
somebody picked up i talked about my mom
and i lived in section eight for a
little while which is subsidized housing
yeah yeah but then they made it sound
like i grew up in
subsidized housing it wasn't they were
nice apartments we just that's so fun my
sister my mom lived in section eight in
chicago too it was a really nice they
were nice apartments it's just you have
to help poor single mothers out so she
needed the help but it would they make
it sound on wikipedia if you read it
it's a it's like
it's like i grew up in cabrini green
they make it sound like it's like no no
we were we were but no no we we grew up
in subsidize because my mom was a single
mom look at that it's right there
section 8 housing wait do you know that
address was it 11 11 north dearborn oh
my god you lived where my sister my mom
lived are you serious yes 1111 north
dearborn you literally grew up in the
same building where my sister and mom
live well my mom was supposedly like a
single hoe by the way every by the way
all women that live in those apartments
are huge is that the criteria to get
approved that's single host status over
there it's like coke head finance guys
and single host i don't know what it is
these days but that's great they talk
might they talk a lot about how that was
a really nice building no it was i mean
i mean they're all everything in that
area in the gold coast is like
it's nice it's all i mean i don't know
what they look like now they probably
are all the same maybe we are more
similar than i thought what if we're
related
oh my god we're cousins
cousin
my cousin
you know people call each other cousin
that creeps me out like on the bear the
bear i haven't yet he refers to his
cousin by the he calls him cousin and i
just it drives me nuts what like cousin
andrew no he just says cousin they call
each other cousin and i love the show
that's that's a very like island thing
too yeah hey cause hey cos bruh gonna go
serve today bro cause yeah they call
each other cousins jeremy allen white i
don't know the other actor's name but
the show is great
maddie is in it right yeah i think he ep
it or something i think maddie's got
something to do with the production of
it well you know we call maddie big
ester on the show oh yeah
what do you mean you guys are the same
size about
now is it is there like awkward vibes
here because it's like
why
like that's like your
co-host's ex
who carlos
what are we talking about me yeah
he's my co-host no i'm not so
are you saying is it weird because of
her and bobby yeah only if you want do
you want it to be weird yes obviously
no it's not gonna be
we connected
uh we connected probably differently
than most of bobby's friends would have
connected with her because we talked
real human life [ __ ] right do you know
what i'm saying about that well you're
also a guy that can talk to women like
and like have real coffee yeah
well we had taught we had some moments
that
genuinely um bonded us a lot i mean look
it's like difficult like yes yes where
we would have to call each other every
day for a week and go over process stuff
so it's just more grounded so that's not
awkward at all i mean
our relationship probably will never
change yeah but also you are so fun to
party with
i'm a fun little party boy what are you
guys talking about none of your business
and you're not invited when you do
can you imagine though if we do party
together do you think you'd even show up
like what would the chances if we said
hey text esther that he'll you'll never
come honestly though you guys i would
because i like both of you and it
neither of you are annoying and so i
would go to that but be honest though
how quickly are you going to leave
what's the time frame oh yeah it'll be
like a i'll in my head when i'm on my
way i'll be like only an hour i'm just
going to keep baiting you in like esther
10 more minutes square we'll make out 10
more minutes
okay also by the way santino you posted
your teenage dirtbag photos did you see
my comment no what on tick tock yeah i
don't i don't really run anything on it
i just put it up wait i want to know
what does it say well i look so ugly he
was talking about an ugo literally when
he was a teenager hotter than i expected
no no yeah i want to see him there you
see it right now
somebody from tiktok reached out and was
like you got to post some of your photos
look at that who am i little gangster
boy
look at that that's my high school pause
out if you can that's my that's my
senior picture
look at the frosted bangs
go for it kiddo
and my mother made me shave because in
high school i always i had facial hair
since i was 14. i started growing so
that like with me with the goatee was me
at that's probably 16 or 17 right there
and then
i almost always had facial hair and then
my mother would make me shave for photos
she that was when we were in london that
was us at madame tussauds you want to
talk about white trash you go overseas
to go to madame tussauds
i've been to the madame tussauds in
london that's so trash why and why and
of course i wanted a picture of me
fighting hitler
and my mom took that photo you know what
after that that was before i even knew
you and that's why i knew at some point
in my life
you saved me i saved you and i heard him
there where are your teenage dirtbags
yeah what's up where are your little
nasty photos they're like i don't i
didn't post them i don't know honestly
sometimes i look at my teen photos and
i'm like i look too good like it's too
good for the internet
okay i was talking to lisa traeger and
she was like um i remember esther as the
girl who had gorgeous long hair who oh
who refused to ever put it on a ponytail
but one day she had a crush on a boy who
was in theater or something like that
yeah and ever since then you would wear
it up in like this bun
and she always remembered you as being a
tiny little siren oh my god a temptress
she was in the she was in the class
where i met my
and fell in love with my high school
boyfriend who has now blocked me on all
wait really yeah yeah i drive by his
house i don't know i'm just like really
obsessed with him he dumped me see my
senior year and i like can't get i'm not
over it what do you think it was what do
you think triggered him to dump you
because i can tell you
what do you think seriously it was that
ended the relationship i was mentally
ill no
well then he should then you know what
then shame on him i know that's what
illness is real
we have to uh was he uh let me get well
he wasn't jewish he was like me he was
half right because not jewish yeah
yeah let's we'll beep it out okay what's
his last name beep it out what beep it
out
yeah beep it out don't you beep it out
you say bleep
oh do i say beep i say b but wait it's
it out i have a very important question
were you time out real fast were you a
hot guy in high school no real fast
though the tone is what when when you
when you blank out a cuss word on an
album or a song what's the tone of the
sound what is it
it's beef isn't it it's not it it
doesn't go bleep but it also doesn't
really go beep because it does
yeah we should say boop so boop that out
what was i in high school i was not hot
no i had b i mean look at my high school
for that last one i had big ears
i was tall and skinny so that was
attractive to girls maybe did you get
girls like were you a hot guy at your
school no no no no there were some hot
that we had some hot guys dude chicago
has hot brad
i'm trying to think of bra i shouldn't
say his last name anyway soccer guys
were just the hottest guys in our
schools
small chests big butt bigger dicks big
dicks oh my god
we had to get named kyle uh boop out his
i can't say his last name kyle was known
as the elephant
uh he had a big old [ __ ] dick
everybody knew it
everyone has that one guy for us at
biller high school it was had a thumper
huh i mean just like
not even like it was like an appendage
it really looked like an extra octopus
arm but yesterday oh look i think that i
was very much um on my way to what i
thought was becoming a young gay
teenager look at all the naked women no
i used to get high with this girl i know
who this girl is i used to get high with
her
i 100 know this girl everywhere i used
to get playboy magazines i never shoved
them under my bed i used to display them
in my room did every high school have a
big dick kid because now i'm realizing i
was left out of that conversation at my
high school well the the dick was the
size of you so they were afraid it was
going to threaten their existence it's
probably bigger than your whole body
look at my whale tail whoa
that's sexy
that is sexy it's really in style right
now wait what is that shirt what what uh
what brand of shirt was that what's
something that cost 4.99 at the pasadena
mall but the whale tail was the you know
the head that was the move back then
yeah and my my belly button ring and i
had my eyebrow pierced my tongue pierced
oh my god the tongue pierced girl boy do
i love her
remember that girl i always wanted to be
the tongue do i have any chance no
chance i'm just it's just not your
personality i don't think so you could
still pierce your tongue today and be it
would look normal if you did it honestly
i'd be so bummed out
it made me sad well i just think you're
you'd be like too into molly or
something i'm like esther's changing in
a weird bad way yeah she's getting into
psychedelics too and it's creepy she's
going to a lot of raves it's sad it'd be
sad at our age oh [ __ ] really we're
older dude okay but i feel like you
could just
yeah i think there's a way
in
for esther
yeah we just
i just don't
i think you're just your personality is
so
your style and your personality
it works it's done you did okay you
can't change again i think you're done
okay i think it's because you're v it's
very clear what you are yes you have a
very very clear um
um
brand okay
no you are it is the hot which is a good
thing
it's not the hot chick no it's your
brand beach babe your brand is like the
chill
sweet
cutie but unassuming
cutie what the [ __ ] carlos don't what me
she's not a chill sweet
well you guys relationship is toxic
that's your problem
oh wait wait i have a question is esther
chill with everyone else
she's chill with me but maybe it's
because she knows better than to not be
chill with me
kalyla you
pretty much use your athletic greens
every day every single day and when i'm
not at home i take the packets with me
this is how i start my day this is an
indispensable part of my day i love the
way it tastes i use my little mocha stir
i put a little scoop in cold water and
it's so good and i feel so so
generally good about myself i have to
say
it's just so convenient that you're
literally absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens all
to help you start your day right so
for me i'm very lazy and i don't want to
think ever so for me the fact that i
have a little packet of of ag one on my
counter i grabbed that i know now i
don't need to keep track of what i'm
eating like i can have pizza and i'm
like i'm good i already had my nutrition
for the day yeah and if you're somebody
on the go this just eliminates all
planning or thought around or even guilt
about not getting your greens in or your
vitamins and minerals
it's lifestyle friendly whether you eat
keto paleo vegan dairy free or gluten
free and it contains less than one gram
of sugar
something i really like about ag-one is
that it's actually way more affordable
because if you were to buy out all these
supplements separately it would just be
way too confusing and way too pricey but
this ends up costing you less than three
dollars a day and you get everything in
one fell swoop and it doesn't taste bad
which i like
was so hard for me to actually believe
that when you told me that but it has
like some kind of like apple juice
concentrate or something in it and it
tastes good it's so mild tasting yeah it
is it's refreshing even they nailed it
and right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into the flu in cold season it's
just one scoop in a cup of water every
day that is it no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health and to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.comtuesdayagain
that's athleticgreens.com
tuesday to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance my most favorite
sound in the world wait for it wait for
it wait for it
oh the rush of dopamine that gives me if
that's how that really works and it's 90
degrees outside it's been such a warm
week here in la and i swear to you guys
nothing quenches my thirst quite like
this beautiful green tall boy
drinking water out of a can has actually
made me a better human and i don't i
can't scientifically prove it but i feel
it what's more important than feelings
why is it called liquid death
because it's death to plastic ester
that's right and 10 of the profits from
every can sold are donated to help kill
plastic pollution and by the way you
guys this is usually what you see this
white tall boy but now liquid death has
all sorts of really
amazing tasting three new flavors
sparkling waters the one i have here is
severed lime there's mango chainsaw and
bury it alive and all of their flavors
have three grams of agave nectar in them
i really personally my favorite is lime
dude when i mix the lime liquid death
seltzer with a splash of cranberry juice
it is the perfect dream mocktail like
that really like helps me just get in
the zone at night oh also it's a good
replacement like for soda if you're
trying to kick soda you have to replace
the habit with something
better that's still going to make you
happy but that's better for you these
are perfect for that and also like
for me i'm not particularly like a heavy
drinker but so when i go to social
events or parties and i never know what
to do with my hands this is a good
solution to that i always have this
really cool can in my hand and no one
gives a [ __ ]
you see these cans popping up everywhere
liquid death is available at your local
amazon target albertson safeway 711 or
sprouts but that's not all because now
you can rock liquid death merch that
crazy logo you know and love is now
available on sweatshirts hats even
licensed plate holders esther and [ __ ]
don't you dare pay for shipping okay go
to liquid death dot com slash trash to
get free shipping on their crazy limited
edition merch and apparel that's
liquiddeth.com trash for free shipping
on their crazy limited edition merch and
apparel
liquid death murder your thirst
actually on my way over here i had a
topic to bring up which was carlos has
bde from his time working at the dog
rescue oh wow what is that what do you
mean bt wait i think this is minorly
abusive by the way it's
guys
what's bde he's just big dick energy he
has soccer boy energies no he does but
he has a nice [ __ ] he used to work at a
dog rescue and he's really good with
dogs and i think that's very bde yeah
people that love also people that love
dogs i think have secure [ __ ]
even dudes who love
clocks
oh my god
but i think dudes who like cats even
bigger dicks even bigger dicks of guys
like cats yeah because guys who like
cats are secure they are not like
yearning for attention they just know
they're okay with getting it whenever
the cat needs it i'm just gonna say marc
maron but then there's gotta be
but then there's sad cat guy so sad dog
guy doesn't exist but sad cat guy
definitely exists there's a fine line
yeah i think sad dog guy is a thing no
because
there's
the the sad cat guy will eventually have
19 cats yeah that's a very very sad and
sad dog and dog guy who had 19 dogs fun
guy yeah what does he have a rescue at
his house now he's a [ __ ] mega ball
guy
yeah that guy's the [ __ ]
have you guys ever heard of this artist
named louie wayne no i think that's his
name well over time he grew like he he
initially had one cat and it turns out
that there is something in the feces of
the cat that alters your brain chemistry
yes yes over time he
kept hoarding cats hoarding cats he
became crazier and crazier and then his
art started to become even wilder and
wilder over time so at first he was just
drawing like a basic cat and then it
turned into these like psychedelic cats
because the cat feet the cat so in cat
fecal maker matter i swear to god this
is real i do know what you're talking
toxoplasmosis yes dave has mentioned
this too so it literally does change the
chemistry in your brain right so that's
why they say pregnant women should not
clean the litter because toxoplasmo
gandai i think it's the will you say
[ __ ] again
that's all she really wants
what's the ugliest word a male genitalia
can be referred to um i probably it's
probably the filipino word for it what
is it
uh with an ant
that does not sound good we're not
making up one's like duty stick or
anything dude
is that an it's an anal dick always yeah
why is it called a duty step because he
said the worst thing it could be and i'm
like poop and it's a stick
what do you think well i mean that one
probably takes the cake
no i just think like i'm talking about
in referential terms of like penis [ __ ]
schlong
wiener hog
like what are the what do you think is
the most gross of those because right
like what's the worst name for for a
vagina do you think oh um like what
bothers you the most pee pee hole
pee pee
is not hole the vagina i know that's why
it's a bad one oh yeah you're okay like
like [ __ ] cooch
dash is pretty bad crash is bad you do
not dare hey i'm not i'm not referring
to your gash i'm just saying
uh [ __ ] cooch gash uh slit
that's okay
also um an asian slur i think yeah yeah
it is it is but can you say that to an
asian girl about her vagina a slit slit
i'm i'm licking your slit you slit dirty
little slit
what's the worst word then what bothers
you the most
ah
i see minge on there that's ninja i love
mentioning this is so great it's a uk
word yeah you like mint mint it's so
good that doesn't sound cute that sounds
like it could be a dog's name it sounds
like gringe
and gringe is close to grinch for you
gringe is just like dirty how about
fanning i like fanny spanish classy i
think lady bits that's not real bits
yeah lady bits really i've never heard
that before
uh fufu oh that's what esther wants hers
to be yeah
is kind of tight what's the one but blow
that one up below it what does that say
a beaver oh yeah beaver beaver
girls i used to babysit would call it 2d
and so if it was hurting they'd say
ouchy tooty but tooty sounds like a fart
yeah that's the wrong side oh we're
we're all very different
beep and boop you know
yeah no you never had an ouchy tooty
my dad would have to would make us say
at the table if he wanted to excuse
herself to go to the bathroom sure of
course we'd have to make a formal
announcement it was um
may i pick some flowers may i pick some
flowers
yeah and that is a way of saying i gotta
go [ __ ] you were never allowed to say i
gotta go number two i gotta go poo
nothing it's may i pick some flowers is
that is anyone flagging that as child
abuse that is so weird he was also not
abused 90 000 years old yeah he was like
he was a monk
they had to pray before they [ __ ] for
like an hour and a half what did you say
when you had to excuse yourself did you
not have to do that no you were allowed
to just get up did you not do formal
dinners no i was raised with no manners
no rules i see that yes yes the more i
know you the most the more i know you
were raised with a lot of manners you
were raised with like they all went out
the window yeah i know but that's why
they go out the window like because
you're in it's like embedded in that
like did you guys sit at the same spot
at dinner every single every time yeah
we did that oh you didn't have were you
in a strict household
no i mean i was just i was such a bad
kid that like
i was kind of uncontrollable it was like
my dad was militant because his dad was
a military guy so our house is was
so clean it was disgusting go look at my
car it's it'll make you throw up there's
nothing inside of it oh you're so you're
like american psycho gross yeah it's
gross okay i had the opposite effect
where everything was kept so clean that
i'm like a crazy slob now but i think
it's because i wasn't like trained to do
it i was it was beat into me because my
dad was always like it
uh it cost money
you didn't pay for it so if you [ __ ] it
up you will have to pay for it just like
if i got something as a gift it was like
you have to respect this otherwise you
don't get stuff like this anymore so
like in my mind i was like i can't [ __ ]
up anything so when i started to buy my
own [ __ ] i still had that like well i
better keep this nice because i bought
it and otherwise
i don't even know the universe will yell
at me for being
dirty it's really creepy kind of awesome
though and um do you like that or not no
i [ __ ] hate it dude you do i can't
have like a shirt on a chair in a living
room it'll [ __ ] me up i have to oh god i
really want to see
you live with bobby just for watching no
i would kill myself i would literally
kill myself just one week please no dude
i'm so i'm like sometimes i am
i like get scared of how annoying i am
with i have to leave i'll be late let's
say i'm late to come to here
if there was a couple of dishes i was
like i just gotta knock that out
it's nuts i'm a [ __ ] it's gross it's
sad my mom too but that's because my dad
beat that [ __ ] into me it stunk i hate
it was like why are there shoes by the
door
you're like i just came home i got beat
i it got beat into me too but i
it didn't keep it didn't keep no
they they don't hit you hard enough dude
you got hit
more than that i had to kneel on rock
salt what yeah it's like you don't know
that ew that's so mean
yeah so you there's this filipino um
torture tactic where
you make kids kneel on rock salt and it
wasn't like
you know the trader joe's himalayan you
know not the nice [ __ ] no it's like
giant stones stones
and then
over time in two hours eventually it
would you know develop a wound and the
salt would seep into the wound
so it was
yeah it's
so not chill not chill no no no but what
that's not we didn't have any torture i
mean my dad would hit us for sure i mean
me not my sister but like i would get
hit you didn't have names for the types
of tortures that would
like we had one called stomach belt
and it was pretty self it's pretty
selfish let me guess whatever yeah yeah
stomach belt but you would have to lay
down you couldn't just take it standing
no you could lean flat you have to lay
on the bed um and expose your stomach oh
my god and you would just have to take
it
which is kind of better because if you
block it with your hand then your hands
get whipped and it's even more painful i
remember that you just have to like
really good core workout oh yeah that's
why you're in good shape yeah my dad
would hit this thing this i got that a
lot i would get cracked on the [ __ ]
head it hurt me so i hated it and then i
learned that when i flinched
uh it was worse
so it was like just take it like a
[ __ ] man and stand there because you
[ __ ] up i always [ __ ] up by the way
i was a bad kid it wasn't you have to
check their hits it's just like in ufc
or in mma you cannot like don't you
gotta check it you gotta go forward take
that [ __ ] hit dude i will say that my
dad used to do this thing where he'd go
like this and he like whoa in your
throat yeah i was gonna say for a second
as a jew this whole i was like what is
that
what is your dad doing
role-playing as a nazi in his own house
all the time and i and i think literally
dave carlos and benji have all picked up
on that if they go like this i go like
this and they're like
why did you think i was gonna hit you he
would hit your neck yeah
i think that's the worst
yeah that's way worse than a rock
shelter
belt stomach doesn't sound worse than
stomach belt esther this stomach any day
you need your throat to swallow yeah no
it was i still
were you argumentative with your dad i
think so yeah is that what this is is
like a shut up thing like him saying be
quiet yeah
now as an adult because he still does it
it's more just like
to scare me out you want me to fight
your dad
i'll
beat the [ __ ] out of that guy
i thought there was a time when
i was scarier than my dad
and that flip was very weird like is
there a time when your mom because like
my sister and my mom always i mean it
was like constant constant
mother-daughter [ __ ] like always
fighting
and me and my dad always fighting and
then there was a day when i like
bigger than my dad
and it was almost like oh i'm i'm scared
i'm scarier than you are i'm stronger
than you and then my mom was saying like
when my sister like grew up
it was almost like two women fighting
instead of mother daughter do you know
what i mean and it was weird to like
watch it happen like do you guys
remember that happening when you're like
i'm an adult i'm fighting with them as
an adult not as their child we did my
mom did it in a very formal way like we
wrestled
what yeah we i um i was maybe 23 at this
point and my mom is somebody who has a
hyper focus on achievement and um
human physical aesthetics like you she
like has a six-pack she has yeah she's
jazz she works out every day jesus and
but at that point i was just coming off
of you know college i was still pretty
like yoked and she'd beat me my whole
life and
there was a point where i looked at her
and she'd always always compared she
always thought she was stronger than me
and i think one day we were at my
sister's apartment
and i was like fine let's wrestle and we
wrestled
and it ended with her head going through
a window because she like tried to do a
takedown
and i just like dipped to the side and
she lunged straight into a window and
she cut herself on a forehead did you
feel bad i did feel bad because it
wasn't even anything i did to like hurt
hurt herself yeah
and at that point i was like okay like
like we're level yeah we're leveled now
my equivalent to that which i wonder if
you guys have had this experience but
it's more like
that i'm older and smart now so it's
like sometimes i actually know better
and i don't like life stuff yeah
do you have that
no but well i mean i argue with my
parents a lot like my dad and i getting
a lot of arguments but the arguments are
always
fundamental
it's not opinion i mean it's only
opinion based there's no fact to it so
it's like
our politics are very different so it
goes nowhere yeah well we argue for no
it's like we'll never stop arguing and
nobody win everybody loses so like
even if i'm like i'm right about this
i'm not to him it'll never you know oh
yeah we never so
i'm trying to think i know what you're
saying a little bit but with us it's
always a fight of
your belief system so i never it's never
like
i'm smarter i'm more right it's always
like we just are fundamentally very
different people
i'm like pretty big into reading reviews
well especially if it involves your
health how hard is it
oh i was just thinking like if i was
going to get fries at a place or not but
no yeah
that's what we're talking about yeah you
go you go
so you say it
well for me at least like when i've had
to um look at look for a doctor
um let's say for instance two weeks ago
we both needed an ent an ear nose and
throat doctor and usually i just rely on
word of mouth but what if my friends
have not don't have a reference or a
good recommendation for an ent doctor
now you can go on zoc doc where you can
search for doctors
who
specific to their specialty and you can
read reviews by patients who've seen
them honestly like finally
i'm really annoyed of all the power that
doctors hold over us and we kind of need
a place where we can all
go
discuss help each other out because from
the patient's perspective i think is the
most important perspective and i want to
hear from other people who've seen the
doctor with zocdoc you can find the
right doctor for you in your network and
in your neighborhood
zocdoc is a free app that shows you
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance and are actually
available when you need them and on
zocdoc you can find every specialist
under the sun whether you're trying to
straighten your teeth fix an achy back
get a mole checked out anything else
zocdoc has you covered and zocdoc's
mobile app is so easy i've used it it's
as easy as ordering at a restaurant or
getting delivery to your house you
search find and book doctors with
literally just a few taps every month
millions of people use zockdoc and i'm
one of them it's my go-to whenever i
need to find and book a quality doctor
go to
zocdoc.com
trash and download the zocdoc app for
free then start your search for a top
rated doctor today
many are available within 24 hours
that's zod
oh my god i literally lost it all right
that's z-o-c-d-o-c
dot com slash trash zoc doc dot com
slash trash say it three times fast or
else
i've told this before this makes me
laugh this is like
a family friend of ours
there is a grocery store
that is near a neighborhood where
you know whatever it's it's a lot of
younger hips hipstery people whatever in
chicago yeah and our family friend she
says at dinner
she's like one of my mom's friends and
she's like you know that's that's the
lesbian jewel that's the lesbian jewel
and i was like what are you what do you
mean the lesbian jewel jewel is a
grocery store in chicago jewel oscar not
anymore i think they're gone right she
was like that's the lesbian jewel and i
was cracking up eating i was like what
do you mean the lesbian jewel she's like
it's exclusively for lesbians
and i was like that's not true there was
no grocery store just for lesbians there
should be yeah there should and by the
way we're starting it today
and she goes she goes yeah i mean you
can tell and i was like how can you tell
and now i'm being now i'm being an
[ __ ] like now i'm trying to and she's
like well they all
you know they all have
very short hair and they dress like boys
and i was like i don't know if that's a
tell and she goes really do you know a
lot of
regular women
that have short hair dress like boys and
i was like what do you mean regular i
was just baiting her
but by the way i did go that is that was
the lesbian jewel there was no doubt
about it
everyone's just eating each other's
[ __ ] it was insane like on the belt
to where your groceries go on that move
it was just uh just woman after a woman
it was not
the lesbian jewel god bless jewel god
bless jewel by the way they're gone they
died i know what is it called mariano's
took over i i do like mariana they're
incredible yeah what was your kid
grocery store what was like the good one
in the philippines yeah no no here when
you were here
um
what's the sexy one mariano's like the
sexy we were not we didn't have a lot of
money so we were you know [ __ ] broke
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm the real section eight
yeah you were we're a fake section yeah
i mean i remember when i first came here
the rent that i mean the check that my
dad wrote out for um rent every month
was 300 and it was a one bedroom
cockroach infested maybe like
300 square foot oh my god like thing and
yeah
300 yeah what was your first rent when
you moved to la
i remember mine to the number four 428
950 in a studio with 10 inch clip well
you paid 9.50 that's a lot what year did
you move here uh i moved in 2009 what
about you oh
oh 607 was when i oh six i moved to long
beach i slept on a lazy boy for a while
right i lived in long beach
we had a connection we never even knew
and then i slept on a lazy boy then when
i made it up to la i lived with a bunch
of ucla grad students and it was 428 i
lived in a dining room when did you what
year did you start doing like open mics
oh seven about okay like about oh seven
yeah but i lived in a [ __ ] dining
room that that the previous owner had
just built
like it was an old you remember how old
houses in l.a they all had sectioned off
every room was its own thing yeah so the
dining room was kind of walled off they
just built two door uh what do you call
those um the in in the wall doors you
know the farmhouse stores
yeah whatever those are um pocket doors
they built two pocket doors and so that
was my bedroom a dining room my [ __ ]
ceiling light was a chandelier
so 428 got me by and and we shared one
bathroom four dudes one bathroom
it was a [ __ ] nightmare but 428 bucks
i was like i can do that i can do it i
can find 400 a month
and i did somehow i mean i remember
there was a couple of nights that i had
panic attacks
because i was scared i was never not
going to be able to afford it and my
parents were never like the
send me i never got money from my
parents never once i felt like did you
no i didn't i never did i never once
i feel like my parents would say that
they did because i i've said that before
and they've been like no we helped you
with like an oil change but i worked
like
three or four jobs and my most
sustainable rent was when i was
splitting the studio with a woman and it
was like 500 a month and i was like i
remember feeling once i've gotten to
that situation i was like i can pay this
yeah you can afford it like i can do
open mics and i can like babysit by the
way helping with an oil change that
doesn't count i mean like i had friends
that their parents would just send them
like three grand yeah and i was like
what the [ __ ] that was never even an
option for me like my dad had died i had
my mom who was working like a minimum
wage job like what other option did we
have than to make sure we always had a
job right where there was always some
type of way to like hustle on the side
and do whatever you needed did you guys
have desperate moments like i i saw
asthma i stole groceries from i sold
plasma that was a big one
oh yeah you could you used to be able to
sell it right i don't think you can
anymore right i think you can't do it
there's probably now they're probably
like oh that's bad that we let you guys
do that for years but i would sell
plasma in arizona i did it what is it no
it looks like you can you still can yeah
i know my friend did in california i did
it i made one because it's more money
than oh it's way more money yeah i did
at one point
nude modeling for art students because i
had read in madonna's biography that she
did it that's such an esther thing for
the money
first because madonna did it yeah but it
was good money but
um
yeah no i you didn't do it no i did it
you did yeah and sometimes i wonder what
are we talking like csun or something
where was it it was actually i did that
in college it was in in champaign
illinois where i did it you went to u of
i
yeah for two and a half years smarty
smarty over here no i got in through the
dance program oh that's fake yeah that's
gross
i probably owe albertson's uh
give or take three thousand dollars
worth of groceries see i disagree
they're a big box store [ __ ] them okay
[ __ ] them you they owe you yeah i think
at some point if the community is hurt
and people are that poor grocery stores
should be supplemented in a way where
they're like
you know and look this is food stamps
right but they should be able to go
i think some of these people get some of
the stuff on the house yeah and just
look at the self checkout lines weren't
as you know
great as they were as they are now and
you could just get blocks of cheese
steal it and just yeah take it with you
and then i remember my sister and i
because we didn't have a car um this is
before they freaking magnetize the
shopping carts we would just take the
whole shopping cart home yeah because it
was just too heavy all the things we had
just stolen the blocks of cheese
you know like and they also learned that
teenagers would take those and then ride
in them and crash them yeah you know
what i mean
we used to do that all the time me too
it's so fun
when i moved here like it was i now i'm
realizing i think that me like quitting
school and moving here was sort of a
reaction to watching both my parents
lose their jobs in the recession because
i was like what what am i doing what am
i working towards if like my parents
could just lose their job at any moment
i think that is like why i quit school
and moved here but that's also why like
i knew that getting money from them like
was not a what did they both lost their
job and was always
yeah wow what did they do
my dad worked in sales and my mom was a
receptionist she's still she's a
receptionist now i think she was also a
receptionist then too office manager
thank you we don't call it that really
is that true i don't think they say
receptionist anymore i think it's like a
it's like anything you can't yeah every
term has a more um
[Music]
it's a less mean word yeah you know like
you know we you know obviously you can't
say like
steward and stewardess
you have to say
bad about receptionist uh i think there
might it just sounds diminutive maybe
really okay and honestly i kind of agree
in a weird way it sounds like you're
just a phone person
like can people still be called
secretaries no that one's that one
definitely no no they said really no
they say um executive assistant so
yeah executive assistant their name is
now but you could still be like
secretary of state that's different
that's true that is true you can be the
secretary of state not the same thing
but yes that is true carlos will you be
my secretary
no
i think that might be what you are
though well you do sexually abuse him
executive assistant is like what i
thought you basically no never mind no
i'm going to say the n-word and get this
cut
caught andre's n-word
bobby shop there i'm going to say the
n-word again
yeah no i don't i don't think i think
the terms are people are sensitive about
certain terms but i do get when if you
work as
an assistant to somebody look my dad
when he he was a he worked in sales
the woman that worked with him worked
with him but was technically a secretary
but dude she did so much so i think at
some point people realize it's like it
sounds diminutive to be like oh you're
just my little phone person okay but
it's more they're more they they do a
lot of [ __ ] so you're like
you know
that i think they're more important than
the word the for some reason
the word doesn't like sound like you're
important so they have to like move it
around i think it's what
people made of that word correct the
really formal word yes the words there's
a lot of hard consonants there
secretary yeah but it also sounds uh
boring like when i say secretary the
woman you think of in your head right
now and woman that's another pro that's
not right i immediately go to woman but
when you say when you say secretary what
does she look like go well i think of
mad men yeah same exactly that's what i
mean so i think they want to i think the
idea is to break away from all that yeah
rebrand yeah like i always think i
always think glasses short bob hair and
very overweight okay right away that's
the image i have the opposite you think
of 1950s
yeah glamorous hot sexy leggy no i like
a fat secretary
give me a porker dude i want someone
who's eating all day nine to five she's
eaten non-stop she's got a big gulp on
her [ __ ] desk
and she's got the let's do this
you want to be my secretary you know
what she's got and she's got the thing
on the phone that you can rest on your
on your [ __ ] rest on your shoulder do
you know what i'm talking about there's
an attachment to the phone she has that
she has a she has a picture of all of
her kids on there but they're not her
kids they're just like kids from the
neighborhood
that she feeds you want to be my fat
secretary yes everything you're
describing i'm like that's that there is
an energy there that i'm drawn to like
why is that like you can't
you can't get fat
what are you talking about i don't think
it's a part of your i don't think you
would let yourself get fat well that's
also because i have disorders
from my mom's but you could get fat the
fact that that's where this was going
you could get fat
i could see you getting so [ __ ] fat
like i could see me like
you know see running into you for 20
years down the road somewhere
and i'm like [ __ ] esther
and you're in one of those like you know
motorized carts and you're like
oh my god
oh my god the obesity scooter and dave
is [ __ ] jacked as [ __ ] he's in the
best shape he's ever been somehow i
think that this is your like dream
your dream ending
yes and then i could even have my own
show on like 600 pounds that's what you
really want
if you can hook me up with a signature
from dr now uh-huh
a dream you saw i had him do um you know
who this is don't you no oh my god he's
a doctor from six my 600 pound life he's
like you're too fat you need to lose all
the weight did you get a um yeah i got a
cameo done for you
i did
so so for my tour dates i hit i cameoed
him and i was like and i just wrote hey
will you say andrew santino's on tour i
put it on my instagram and he was like
he's like come see andrew do
comedy for october four to five dude
it's so great and then half of the
people that got it i loved because then
i know who my audience is because i
think this guy's the funny he's mean he
is so mean
if you don't lose weight you will die
and it looks like your will die
i mean he's just like it's way down
there i want to keep i don't know how
far it is but you'll see it keep going
maybe it's um
oh i want to see you'll he'll pop up
it's his face do you know what darius
there he is
and by the way same day cameo
i gotta give him a shout out dude same
day cameo was [ __ ] because most of
the time you book a cameo
and many other they'll get back to you
in a couple of days maybe a week by the
weekend
i'm so jealous i might just get myself a
cameo from just to keep for myself what
a cutie pie too look at this little cute
face
i feel like he could really motivate me
to do what i need to do well here's what
i'll say about um
andrew's predictions of your um fat
years okay um
her dream
ending to her life because you know
she's she's
she's a
a very well-known porn star yeah
and she is also she's always felt the
pressure of looking a certain way you
know eating a certain way and she's
always said i want to be in a feeder
relationship
where someone just really gets a kick
out of just constantly feeding me
feeding me feeding me and i just want to
be this like
massive
thing is that your little wet dress
but people say that hot girls say that
all the time i think she means it
okay she spent her whole life being
skinny and hot she's probably exhausted
yeah it's exhausting yeah you know what
have you ever talked to someone that's
in like a really really good shape like
yes they're they're miserable as [ __ ]
well there are a lot of tick tocks now
of men with like obviously very amazing
physique who are like i [ __ ] hate my
life i hate having to keep this up it's
exhausting it sucks the food is bland
like it's just i would much rather be
normal same i would much rather be a
normal like my body's fine i'm okay with
it it's not impressive it's not sad just
let me eat [ __ ] burgers when i feel
like it girls what do you think of these
pigs
i think and well it's different for
andrew because he's over 510 so he can
have some weight on him yeah i look
better with a little bit of weight yeah
if i'm too skinny six one is weird with
with
yeah like five seven isn't you gotta be
like you gotta be fit an actor yeah
that's right look you know emil hirsch
style are you struggling are you are you
miserable are you okay are you hungry a
lot i am hungry a lot but i like it i
want to look like this
i don't like want to feel weighed down
but okay
what does kate moss say nothing tastes
as good as being thin peels yeah nothing
tastes as good as how being thin feels
there's just no way that's true but
andrew's happier than us he's like
married and working yeah but no no i'm
not happier because of the body stuff i
just that's just the thing i've
succumbed to going i'm gonna do this is
my i don't care anymore
i think you also get an age and you're
like [ __ ] leave me alone
i don't but you're also super fit
no i'm i'm fit but i'm also like i still
don't i don't ever i don't want a
six-pack i don't care about all the i
just want to stay healthy you're healthy
suffering i just want to be healthy
that's all yeah no but like look at the
difference like to have a stone face and
still face look at carlos's still face
right
and now look at pete's still face
pete's a happy boy he's a little easy
he's my little thicky thicky boy and
he's happy and carlos has said he has
the life yes
he goes out all the time well he's
married to a mega babe yeah yeah he he
spares himself no expense on life he
likes to live the way he wants to live
and like he's happy you you're sad boys
yeah
and you want food buddy drinking at work
oh my god carlos you know what it's
saturday
to him at saturday
i've realized that
pete you're actually more my type like i
like thick and sweet
i mean i mean not in like uh i'm just
saying is a generally i'm i'm into thick
and sweet yeah pizza [ __ ] because pete
is a protector let me tell you something
somebody tries to steal the beads off
your neck in an alleyway like they did
to batman's parents pete's gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of him isn't that right
pete but what's carlos going to do
that's [ __ ] right see ccc when you
have palms you know it's serious what's
carlos going to do please please
take them take them
we'll get more [ __ ]
that's
so true dude that's great
we'll get more [ __ ]
or you're like shoot her
that's so funny there's a topic that i
want to esther and i have been going
back and forth about
which is men prefer the company of men
always yes and that
it just so happens that they're dick
points in the woman's direction but if
that weren't the case you would actually
rather live with a man
oh my god yeah that's not even oh my god
yeah so you agree 100 i would much
rather live with a guy my a buddy of
mine yeah oh my god those are some of
the best years of my life like i didn't
like having roommates but i loved living
with a buddy like i love i love the idea
of waking up
and seeing someone in the living room
smoking getting high and i get to go sit
and just get high with them my also my
it was different time in my life but
[ __ ] yeah dude dudes are way easier to
live with but you're choosing to be
married to a woman because because
society tells me so
i don't want him
no because i can't [ __ ] dudes i just say
hey i cannot that's a that's a personal
choice you know i just i i couldn't [ __ ]
one of my buddies but i could live with
them for sure why is it then that we are
subjecting ourselves to these long-term
relationships and living you know
cohabitating with someone we don't
necessarily couldn't agree with you i
would rather
me and another married friend i met i'd
rather me and him live together and then
our wives lived i want to do that too i
would 100 want to do that i think the
wives would like that too yes of course
they would it's
the the the reason that i think most
relationships go to [ __ ] at some point
like especially long term is because
once you live with someone long enough
it's it's really it becomes difficult to
love them the way you did when you
didn't see them all the time you know
it's just you you see ever you see all
of them you see every part of them you
smell their [ __ ] you see the way they
walk the way they sit the way they eat
like the fantasy is gone and appointment
[ __ ] is gone like you remember when
used to call who you were dating and
they're like do you want to come over
later and you're like yeah and you get
excited on the drive to go [ __ ] because
you're like dude we're gonna [ __ ] it's
amazing like the drive is whimsical like
it's a good song is on if the night
feels right but now you're like
you wanna [ __ ] you know it's kind of
like a right we have we have we better
do something we haven't [ __ ] in x
amount of time right and we're watching
a movie and yeah oh my god should i move
out from dave
yes because he's he's very similar to
you he's always like i loved the best
time of his life was living with his
friends
and he always will be like of course i
wish i was gay i would love to have sex
with my best friend i just they're none
of my friends
that's not my that's not my perspective
i was saying it wrong it's basically
what you said like i would love to live
with my friends and then go [ __ ]
the woman i love that would be amazing
but society is like you have to live
together well society is
i don't know why under the the you know
assumption that
men and women will have will raise the
family together so you need both mom and
dad okay but before the kids are there
right then why do we do it why do we do
it and by the way why can't we raise the
kids as a community that's gonna be a
whole thing too please my
dream my dream scenario is a compound
with six houses sort of close by with a
common courtyard and all of my friends
raising kids together this is not a cult
all of my friends raising kids together
but not necessarily me living with my
partner especially let's assume like
with bobby say for instance one of our
biggest biggest like
points of contention is really the way
he lives and has no regard for
um how sloppy or what slob he is right
and i i i receive that as like a form of
disrespect where it's like how can you
have me clean up after you all [ __ ]
day long so it's like if you eliminate
that and we don't live together and we
it's almost like a preservation of this
love yeah that we have and i don't need
to see what a [ __ ] slob you are we
could just like [ __ ] hang out you're
dating forever basically it's like yeah
no you get to keep the only problem with
that theory is with the people living in
the thing
maybe this isn't an issue but you know
what what starts happening is that
everyone's gonna be [ __ ] everybody
but then also and if you're cool with it
you're cool with it but you know i might
be cool with it that everyone will start
[ __ ] everything true oh without
always proximity dude proximity [ __ ]
i dated uh so one of my ex-boyfriends um
was in kind of that commune was raised
in a commune like that and everyone was
you have yeah
even this dude well carlos is the only
one are you trying to feed the dog
bananas
men eat hot dogs yes
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hot dogs there's always a guy recording
that's such like a bro thing on tick
tock or on instagram you'll see a guy
like he'll look around he'll like eat a
hot dog by himself and then someone goes
goop and he's like [ __ ] throws the
hot dog away
but no i'm not afraid did you see that
guy who used what do you call it when
you use a hot dog or you turn a hot dog
into a straw i love that [ __ ] so much
have you seen this no oh my god there
was a guy that had a picture of video of
a guy at the yankee game it's all over
the internet now he took a straw poked a
hole through the hot dog and then put
the hot dog in his beer and drank the
beer through the hot dog that's cool and
we take little bites it was so [ __ ]
cool look at that sucking back a [ __ ]
miller light with an old wiener do we
know asian thing about why he did it
well they have there's a video of him
actually puncturing the hot dog with the
straw wait he is he asian
because this would make me so proud can
i tell you something i my gut says yes
yeah let's see the video though you can
go to the video i think the show is this
kind of innovation can only be look like
zoom in on the first picture there you
can kind of see yeah yeah yeah he is
congratulations to us god bless our new
hero these people know what they're
doing
well the thing about is they're just
efficient
imagine the combo of just like hints of
hot dog and beer that's kind of so good
french fries in the milkshake oh french
fries and the milkshake did you
cheeseburger in the milkshake i've never
that was my mom's thing when i so
some once in a while
if i had like a good day and i was a
good little boy
she would take me to a little diner
around the corner
in in river north and i would we'd get
chocolate milkshakes and their
cheeseburgers were small like back when
cheeseburgers were actually like an okay
size now every cheeseburger is [ __ ] a
pound of meat but it was a tiny little
cheeseburger and she would break it in
half and we'd eat each dunk it in the
milkshake and eat it and that was like
one of the happiest i [ __ ]
loved that [ __ ] i have a question
i'm really perturbed by the way you're
eating your banana why
you have been beat your whole life even
the way you hold
the banana and such always hold this and
the way you eat it it's like you know
when they tell you how you're supposed
to drink your soup or it's like the
spoon comes to you you don't come to
this that's how he's doing it well i
suck the deck of at the start so i
didn't want to
to be fair
i really forget how much i like bananas
i never buy them they are great i never
buy them
you need them but when you go to the
grocery store
do you buy bananas every day every yes
bananas we don't do that no that's
that's a that's no that's a jungle thing
whites don't do that
whites don't do that i mean bananas are
a thing that we buy because we think we
might get banana bread out of it oh my
god there's a full pound
if there isn't a banana or if there's an
uh uh what do you call them a bundle uh
bushel a bushel no it can't be
sure it's a bun
sponge
bunch of bananas
in if there isn't isn't a bunch of
bananas
if there isn't a hand of bananas in the
household there's a full-blown panic in
our house why what do you use it for
potassium yeah straight up so you can
also it's a great um antacid so anytime
you're feeling some type of like i know
my mom used to gi like kick up or like
you have like heartburn it's such a a
good feeling to just take a banana down
to the house my mom would give me banana
and sprite if i was ever feeling because
the sugar the carbonation and the banana
i would always like settle my stomach a
little bit yeah it tastes so good though
bananas what did your parents give you
when you guys felt sick
um crackers a little bit of anything
carbonated yeah saltine crackers
and i think that's it probably a good
beating
get better
we'd have my mom a little bit of whiskey
really whiskey a little bit of whiskey
just a little bit of whiskey what the
[ __ ] a little bit just a very small
amount that's not carlos is knotting it
that's not a that's not that's normal
yeah in the 80s
they would rub it on the gums yeah but i
mean when we were kids we could have a
little bit because it would it would it
act as like you know it was a numbing
agent a little bit it calmed you down or
something well it does i mean inherently
when it gets into your bloodstream
especially when you're when you're so
not used to alcohol it does really have
great effect i mean now i'm an addict
but you know
they [ __ ] me up but that and then i
would have um
uh
my mom would make cinnamon toast i loved
cinnamon toast oh so good i love
cinnamon it was like it was my [ __ ] i
almost wanted to be sick because she
would make it just because do you still
love it now i do i actually love you
know what's so funny though is now we're
at that age where you're like how much
bread am i allowed to eat this week i
know that's annoying to say but like i
used to eat bread every day of my life
right every day of my life as a kid and
now i'm like i should eat a little less
[ __ ] bread i know so i relegate what
day i know you know we all know you can
eat us well you probably can't no i
tried these i just saw your brain being
like sandwiches sandwiches
but i just know that eating sandwiches
is not a thing i can do anymore more
than once a week as a grown man because
i feel like [ __ ] yeah uncle paulie's i
[ __ ] love uncle paulie so much it's
so i mean like trust me dude i want to
eat sandwiches
every day yeah but i just know i'm like
this isn't like breakfast is my favorite
meal i want a breakfast sandwich every
[ __ ] day so do i for the rest of my
life i want to wake up if somebody said
you can't have other meals i'd go fine
just give me a [ __ ] breakfast
sandwich if i'm not allowed to eat
anything ever again later in the day
just let me have a big [ __ ] off
cr croissant
fried egg bacon conversation is like are
you getting horny yes literally
triggered well for me
um i've um
i have come to terms with the fact that
i will never give up rice
it's not possible it's so good
but like also white rice for breakfast
with eggs longanisa or like you know
i can never give that up so i have to
give up the breads or the heavy bread
the other powers because it's like look
rice is my number one rice twice a day
yeah well i'm okay i'm pasta over rice
but that's how you grew up you ha you
ate rice with everything yeah i cannot
not eat right see i could not i couldn't
give up pasta if somebody was like you
it's got to go away i'd be like
i like it so [ __ ] much that's my
dirty meal and i eat and i'll eat it
until i'm
sad what carb could you
do away with for the rest of your life
um
yeah honestly i could get f i could [ __ ]
off bread
like i could i could i could i know it
stinks but i could do it it would suck
but to have rice i would get rid of
bread well yeah right isn't that that's
kind of the bread's kind of the weakest
of all of them
rice is so good yeah fried rice what are
we talking shrimp fried rice honestly
just like
sushi with white rice a rice bowl with
anything in it anything mochi is rice
yeah you know so i cannot give up i'm
going to say something controversial and
i really don't care
um
it's all the jew's fault no
no i know the uh
crispy rice with um
tuna on it or whatever [ __ ] off what
please hold on please say that to
bobby's face i hate it dude it's trash
you guys talked about this no i've never
said no please say it's his face on bad
friends because it's [ __ ] how so
it's write that down it's perfect
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's the crisp
first of all the crispy rice
is is not ever almost never done the
right way that i want it it's either too
[ __ ] crispy or shitty and sticky and
the spicy tuna up there it's the
shittiest tuna they have they mash it
and put [ __ ] other [ __ ] in it to make
it preserve here's where you're not
wrong you're not wrong in the sense that
oftentimes it's not done right when they
do get it right yeah but it's rare
that's my point is that every place
makes it and most places i go to i'm
like this is [ __ ] right right and
everyone at the table always wants it
everyone goes yeah should we get crispy
rice the spicy cheese it's like no
because it's a [ __ ] waste i'd rather
have i'd rather have tuna belly i'd much
rather have toro i'd much rather have a
cut of better fish than mashed
refrigerated three-day-old [ __ ] tuna you
put on your burnt rice correct that's my
problem unless you go to a dope place
that makes it well but i just feel like
a lot of la places pump it out for
whites and
because i know you get it here's what
the whites love too they love eel sauce
on everything and everything i'm [ __ ]
like why why because they don't a lot of
whites don't really like sushi news
flash that's me most whites don't
actually like sushi they think they they
think they like the culture of it yes
they don't like it they always opt for
their roles instead of just the but do
most of the time the roles are [ __ ]
they'll get roles that are [ __ ]
right and they just cover it all up in
meals yeah i just like rice and sugar
and i think i'm yeah yeah you're one of
those you're one of those whites you
don't want real good fish no nasty
that's the thing i don't eat it that's
why the most time when i go out with
people you can tell right away by how
people order sushi if they actually like
sushi wait okay what would i do if i
wanted to pretend let me get your order
real fast ready edamame first you're
eating it every time yeah yeah crispy
rice right 100
then you're probably going to do like a
um you're probably going to do like a
crisp crispy onion
sing whatever that is yeah you loser
and then you're definitely getting it
yeah you're getting a california roll
that's 100 what you're going for sure
that's your order that's your crab hand
roll right uh imitation crap by the way
sure for sure it's fake i do love a good
imitation crap i do but also again i
want real fish and [ __ ] what are you
ordering if you're like mystery he's
gonna get a laurel belly yeah he's gonna
get not the regular mackerel he's gonna
get some spanish mac correct
he's probably gonna get uni love uni
he's probably gonna get um monkfish love
monkey he's gonna get tamago
you're hitting all home runs here i am
right that's so good honestly i want
fish
i don't want to go there and eat
accoutrement i don't that's what that's
what the whites do
and the first time i started eating
sushi i ate with non-whites and then you
learn you don't eat the white one the
white version is bad
the white version is bad sushi whites is
bad yeah it's basically what ruined good
sushi is what too much white [ __ ] yes i
am pure middle america white eater like
when my dad discovered sushi it's so
[ __ ] funny he like he was like have
you ever had edimimi and i was like
yeah i've had enemy i swear to god my
dad calls it endomommy
yeah
like they don't know how to and he was
like it's frozen in the freezer you can
put in a microwave you have adami mean
at home and i was like yeah that's great
cook up some medamini
when my dad gets sushi it has to be the
most diluted deep fried sauce ridden
whatever's on the menu that's covered up
the the fish barely exists yes he's like
give me those and then you get to still
feel like oh i'm into i'm a sushi guy
yeah yeah i'm a hot
girl sushi
no we need to take you to get some
[ __ ] real ass sushi where would we go
well i mean
um there are a couple of places yeah you
know what i like you know what i like
sometimes i like gin pachy do you know
jim poche and west hollywood santa
monica it's good it's a ripoff but it's
really [ __ ] good schwartzen and i
like to go that's a little sneaky spot
it's only got like five tables but
they're legit calling things a rip-off
oh it's a rip-off it's a rip-off there
are a couple in little tokyo that aren't
rip-offs and they only have 10 seats and
they are incredible the bomb yeah i
actually have to clarify something from
last week's episode where we're talking
about the ick factor do you know what
that is yeah something gives you the ick
yeah it creeps and grosses you out men
aren't allowed to have the egg or they
can't they think they can and they do
but it's actually they're only just
talking about a turn-off girls solely
have soul ownership of the egg okay then
what would it be for guys i'm not going
to disagree with you because i kind of
know exactly what you're saying but for
men it's like we have the um
what would that be for men like with
women i know what the ick is i know what
you mean it's like uh it's an
irreversible i will like a like a
proportion yeah yeah yeah but so jules
asked me do i ever get the ick after
being with dave for 10 years and i said
yes and obviously i've always forgot
that dave listens to this and so he asks
he does yeah what a psycho
are you okay dave what are you doing he
has to like keep up with what's new with
me this way but
there's no communication in your house
but so i i had said yes i do get the ick
and dave was like what dave was so
concerned that my ick for him was his
face
and i'm like dave no
and i so he wanted me to clarify it
which i did tell him it's his driving
his driving really gives me that pretty
minimalistic ick factor honestly that's
pretty small on the sky it works yeah i
broke up with a guy because of how he
reacted to a cockroach landing on his
shirt oh he freaked out
he acted like like the well he not only
did he act like a [ __ ] but it was the
bartender we we we went into this bar in
mexico and it was an empty there was no
patrons inside
and he was wearing a a sheer white shirt
kind of like you know those white shirts
that aren't very thick
and i could see
that a cockroach had gone into his
shirts right
and instead and i just like ran away
there was a cockroach in your shirt and
i like ran the opposite direction but
from the distance i could see that the
bartender
hopped over the bar and was like trying
to like smack his body because he
couldn't smack it himself because he
didn't want to do this
like this after that i went home and i'm
like this is we got back from vacation
and but the whole time i was like i
can't [ __ ] him tonight i can never [ __ ]
him ever again but that's the it it's
something so dumb
but i'm like this cannot be my life
partner i get that is it for women that
it's like oh you just instantly told my
brain like i can't [ __ ] you because you
won't protect our children yeah it's
probably it's probably primal but some
women describe like some of the ics that
women have talked about it's like when a
dude jumps in the water and he plugs his
nose i couldn't agree with him i
couldn't
yes
also by the way and this is very
personal and i know there's a lot of
people that will call [ __ ] but the
way that people react when bees are
around them is huge for me if you're
this person
when a bee is around you i don't trust
you at all as i think you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you're a [ __ ] it's insane you
stink shut up leave
it does it it's not going to hurt you
it exists and it will not sting you like
it'll be near you as a person who has
orange hair the amount of bees that have
landed on me thinking i'm a flower it's
[ __ ] remarkable
trust me it's not going to hurt you
you're a human flower i have a flat i'm
a big walking flower but bees when i
learned i got stung when i was a kid we
were playing in the backyard and i
remember i remember i got stung like on
my neck
not i didn't even see it happen you know
i mean like i knew what happened i was
like holy [ __ ] and then i thought
oh that's not that bad because all those
years until you get stung you're like oh
i got stung by a [ __ ] when you're a
kid you're like stunned by a bee it's
probably gonna end my life yes then you
get stung and you're like that's okay
that's because we all watched my girl i
know and it killed them oh my god i've
had
like i am such a scared can handle
nothing person and both times where i've
been stung i didn't even know i was
stung yeah it was just such a i was
someone was like i think he got stung if
there is a bee near you this is how you
react
turn your head away until it goes away
that's all you do just go like this
until it goes away it you know it but
the more you
that's me or when i or i see someone at
a restaurant and they'll go ahead
oh god i hope it stings you right on the
[ __ ] face some people are like that
with birds
when a bird flies by and somebody goes
oh like it's
it's it's not doing anything especially
if it's like a small bird like it has
hollow bones now if it was like a
vulture or a condor that's another story
but i'm like that tiny thing has hollow
bones it has hollow bones it has hollow
bones you [ __ ] anyway
you bet you do you little bird you are
such a bird if this room was birds you
would be a little tiny hollow bird like
a little uh what are they what are they
called no no little um a hummingbird no
no no no that's way too pretty
uh no wait what are they called they're
like something with an f
um it's it's it's like a meek little
tiny
a fin a finch yeah you're a finch and
that's the thing those are so good i
mean what's his name had an obsession
with finches that's how he got his whole
theory on evolution yeah that's uh
that's uh uh uh what the [ __ ] darwin
darwin love finches you're a little
finch look at you that's you you are 100
percent offense i see it right yeah it's
cute oh that's me and dave kissing
dave is not a finch i'm sorry to break
it to you he's definitely not a fan okay
so what is the equivalent of an ick for
a guy just a turn off then
i think ick for do i know what you mean
by women having irreversible and where
you're like oof i wish he hadn't done
that now i can't get my mind off of it
for guys it's like i don't know it's
like a just there sometimes
all right this is
one time i dated someone
who was so like overt when we were
having sex about um her noises she was
like it was like over the top like it
was like she was acting for a camera and
she did it all the time which i thought
sometimes if we were drunk i'm like yeah
you're drinking you're [ __ ] over
exerting but like my dick is a normal i
don't have this like big thumper [ __ ] i
have a nice regular [ __ ] so when she was
like oh my god and i was like oh shut
the [ __ ] up like in my head it started
to turn me off so much that one time we
were hooking up and i looked in the
mirror you know the [ __ ] closet
mirrors you know yeah and i caught a
reflection of myself [ __ ] and to
myself am i like this i went
i rolled my eyes
and that was it that literally that like
i was so bothered by how like
overt and fake it was that honestly i
was like i don't want to sleep with you
anymore was there and the sex was so
good was there ever a possibility of
like having a conversation about it no
because you know what that does it
absolutely ruins her sexual ego i mean
you you ruin if you say to somebody
look dude mate in a marriage or in a
long-term relationship you got to go
through sexual conversations that's
different when you're dating somebody
that's so hard to be like and casually
dating by the way like yeah what's the
point even yeah you're you're like we
just just won't [ __ ] anymore and it just
yeah that's the end of it what would i
say to her i mean here's two options
right either too loud either and she was
really really into it and that's just
the truth she was or it was nuts or
you know i've i've been there i've you
know for a long time was programmed to
think my body was just um
not to prioritize my pleasure but to
prioritize his um mental his mind right
state and how he feels about his ego so
i would prioritize his ego over the way
i felt and that involved you know
like louder sounds than i should have
but i learned very quickly that number
one exhausting yes number two why do i
give a [ __ ] about making this dude feel
good right your dick is inside your body
yeah it's already yeah that's enough
um you just can't be silent the other
side of the spectrum is scary oh really
because if you're just laying there like
that's that's some creepy [ __ ] what is
the correct level that it's it's
honestly i think
honestly honesty yes it's the best the
sexual emotion that works the best is
you not holding back so never hold back
if you feel like you want to say
something say it say all of it moan all
of it if you need it out but don't turn
it on yeah you don't everybody knows
when you're like oh yeah everybody knows
that nobody's instinct is to be like oh
[ __ ] yeah it's like what you look it's
learned it's like a point but what is
normal is like
oh
yeah oh like small that was nice was
that your little i was just breathing
out do your come grunt
that's yours
oh no dave
i have to say that i learned what is
your congratulations
i don't have one i don't i'm not loud
when you come you're not loud no but i
wanted i
learned to be very quiet during sex
because one time
i said to a guy you're so hot while we
were having sex and he did not respond
and that was very traumatizing what did
you want him to say you're hot too
that's weird really no yeah but it's
just because words and sex are fake yeah
you're so [ __ ] when i meant it i know
but when a guy is [ __ ] you and he's
like god you're so [ __ ] hot you you
don't go like thank you it's there's no
response that would be weird if you said
thank you yeah these aren't call and
response you when you when it's [ __ ]
talk it's just exists it's almost like
it goes to the ether and disappears
right okay so i think that are you
looking for a response every time
i just think if you're a girl and you
say to a guy you're hot
in and you're having sex
he should probably compliment you but
hang on one second if a guy would be
like a [ __ ] yesterday you're so [ __ ]
hot that's different and then what would
you say i wouldn't say anything well
because i'm the girl oh this is
disgusting we're breaking these gender
norms dude cut it out because what are
you a gen xer what's going on this goes
back to what we were texting about that
a woman's like the way a woman gets
turned on is by feeling desired and the
way a man gets turned on is
maybe this right yeah so there's over
there wait a minute a woman's
a woman okay so basically in order for a
woman we're there we were all having sex
in order for me to want to have sex with
you i have to feel like i want to have
sex with me uh you're right right very
narcissistic it's not narcissistic
that's not the correct term but it's
basically like how i view myself is
basically how i'm gonna um
like if i'm not feeling um
completely in awe of myself in that
moment there's a good chance i don't
want to [ __ ] right and yeah with guys
with something that you got i mean you
guys just will never understand that we
just like we don't understand that
emotion like i don't need to be horny
for myself to want to [ __ ] you it's like
for guys it's a there's a trigger you're
ick we have a trigger
but it's positive so it's basically our
trigger is like oh my god i have to [ __ ]
that thing right now they have
spontaneous arousal we have reactive
arousal that's exactly correct so the
way that you're ick is innate and
instinctual are our click over of like a
thing we see like like like if you're
walking through a part of the house
and just my brain like analyzes a thing
that you're doing whatever it is and
it's like i want to [ __ ] that thing so
bad right it's [ __ ] primal it's like
your insides are like try to [ __ ] that
thing right now for us it's like
our engine needs to be warmed up and
part of that warming up of our engine is
really how we view ourselves so we've
got to kind of want to [ __ ] ourselves
first before i want to [ __ ] someone else
this is this this is probably the best
sex ed class that kids could ever
receive which is it is true because they
don't tell you that [ __ ] they don't talk
about
warming up women when you're young you
have a [ __ ] idea you think you're
supposed to go fast and hard i mean the
like the amount of times i [ __ ] as
hard as i could it was insane yeah it
was i used to try to break their pelvis
it was nuts it was like
not violent i just mean you were like
the harder i [ __ ] the better it is
right that was when you're young you
thought yeah i wanna [ __ ] this [ __ ] like
when you're
20 you think like if you don't [ __ ] hard
you're a [ __ ] also can i just say one
more thing um there's this woman who's
working with this theory and she's on
tick tock but basically it's if guys
were to really [ __ ] according to what
felt good for them instead of what they
viewed in porn or
what the standards that they've learned
it would look very different if they
were really it's called she calls it a
poking pandemic where they've just
learned that thrust thrust poke but it's
actually more pleasurable if there was a
more scooting motion like if you were to
see a guy right when he's coming it does
he's not poking he's like he's scooting
he's he put it it changes
and that's why i get a kick i love to
watch dudes come
without their heads i don't want to see
their faces yeah but like on porn and
stuff i like the way the movement
changes when they're the moment they
come it's different from the just right
well yeah you're right that's why like
uh
when she's on the belly from behind is
one of my favorite i think a lot of guys
it's one of their favorites like if you
lie flat yes yes because it is a
scooping it's a scooping motion scooping
carlos no isn't that one of your
favorites like doggy style is great but
you laying down on your stomach and
we're on top of you from behind that's a
scoop that's a scoop motion
that'll get me to [ __ ]
carlos show us on kalila here
you know what can you show me what this
one guy did to me you're not going to do
you're going to do prison style but
you're not going to lay on top of me
you're actually going to straddle me
like a horse get over here
i'm going to be face down slightly ass
up but only slightly funny peter's uh
pete's like i don't ever get to
demonstrate on this show
they make me just run the boards
yes
yeah straddle yeah because the camera's
catching this
the wives
no no this is legal you're both
consenting adults
this is the position i'm talking about
yeah and by the way i've done that
that's my favorite that's what i'm
talking about that's the one scooting
how did you know how to tell him what to
do
what do you mean me yeah
wait so you she's been scooted before
i've been scooted so many times okay i'm
like learning how to wait a minute have
you never [ __ ] in that position i've
never i've never had sex
she's cut it out right now have you
never [ __ ] like that i don't think
that that's not wrong holy [ __ ] that's
one of my favorites you
guys dave hold on dave where's my camera
dave this one you gotta scoot it buddy
you gotta flip her over let her be on
her stomach and you gotta scoot by the
way you do know why that's really
effective for both parties they don't
have to look at each other yeah
that's exactly it there's no there's no
eye contact you can look down at the
pillow you can fantasize it's somebody
else bumping you it's true and then from
the back every girl looks innocuous
every girl's back in their head and
that's the best one the one that i just
did that scoot's my favorite is that
yours and also the wider you can spread
your legs oh i know you know
you gotta get scooted basically it's
like this esther if i want a guy to like
finish me off even when he's already
like like come from that position i stay
in that position
and i make him like finger me from that
position wow i've done that and they got
they were like weirded out
you know what you're not with that girl
anymore
that's right she didn't know what she
was doing yeah why it's kind of like i
get to bury my face down check out who
gives a [ __ ] who's behind me i get to
focus on my
the sensation without worrying about my
face this makes perfect sense like also
sometimes when i'm in scoot position
i'll put one arm to the side and then
i'll wrap one around to play to play
with your body that's you have long arms
i try this with bobby doesn't work
there's no wrap around there but i'll
give a word to the wise if you're if you
are do have long stems and you're trying
to play get him if you're trying to hit
the button
you might fall your arm sometimes can
fall asleep because the hip pressure on
your arm hurts a little bit so you've
got to really scoot underneath to have
all the weight on your forearm instead
of on your wrist because your wrist will
fall asleep and again guys this only
works if there's a height disparity like
tall guy short girl i can promise you it
doesn't work
short guys do you teach these things
like i feel like you could we're doing
it right now okay
no i'm serious though as you get all the
stuff you learn about particularly if
you if you have a partner that you can
just be honest with about like what you
like and don't like yeah it just grows
the thing where you're like oh great we
don't have to [ __ ] that way because none
we don't neither of us like that way
yeah so then you check out the thing
that you don't like you're like no we
don't great because i don't think i
didn't know if you liked [ __ ] like
that because it's not my favorite and
then they go no i didn't like that and
you're like great so we can
cross it off remember the pressure of
being younger and having to get through
all the positions so insane right you in
your head no one came no one would come
no because you're thinking you're like
all right i have to do this for another
minute and then we'll have to flip into
and then the way i flip her has to be
this way and very like choreographed or
else she's might get the ick right
if i stumble it is true you used to be
conscious of what you looked like having
sex when you were young you thought
there was a camera recording you and you
were like they'll see me looking stupid
so you were always nervous about how you
[ __ ] then you get older and there's
queefs and there's farts and it's and
it's sloppy it's hot it's way hotter
when you don't think about it you can
throw a limb you get you can get hit in
the face and it doesn't ruin the moment
you know what i mean it's fine you just
keep rolling i find that this is all
like a positive advertisement for
having sex with someone that you know
and are comfortable with am i crazy no i
mean well that helps it certainly helps
when you because then you can be honest
and just go you could just be anything
right like and i think that ultimately
that is the best sex you'll ever have is
if there is just no judgment yeah all
you know everything is just open
communicate like there's just no shame
involved it's like that's why
like i'm fine with queefing in fact
queefing has started to feel good i've
talked about this before people did not
like it it was not well received but
it's like that is just part of it all
when i was younger i used to care so
much i'm like i cannot be face down
completely ass up because that will then
create the queef if he pulls out too far
back and puts puts it back in and so i
would always kind of talk like a hyena
and i don't want to do the hyena anymore
i just want to be free and clean be free
let that [ __ ] fly the truth about what
you said is
yes
the fun stuff about [ __ ] a stranger
when you have those moments in life
that fun wears off when you
kind of can't be completely what you
want so then when you are [ __ ]
someone that you know that you're
familiar with
you you don't that's why people go back
to old [ __ ] that's why somebody that's
why we [ __ ] our exes because you're like
dude they know how i [ __ ] and i like how
they [ __ ] me and
even though you don't like the person
you're like i know but the [ __ ] is fun
and they're familiar and it's a normal
[ __ ] that i'm used to right like i went
back to that cockroach guy
um
everybody everybody goes back though he
says that you're like i've never [ __ ]
again he's like everybody goes back to
the cockroach guy because he was the
first guy that i met that really just
with like he with his whole chest like
he would eat ass like with his whole
being and he really so that's something
that was
like what
have you ever had
of course all right relax but there's
eating that's like more like clinical
like this
yeah there was just like he's like i
have my ass seen by all your heroes
seriously just cut that out all right no
leave that in leave that in leave it in
leave that in
um so yeah i went back to cockroach guy
maybe once or twice because he just was
very like he had a voracious ass eater
and i was like this guy i don't have to
worry about
yeah you know he knows what he's doing
but also he just liked everything about
me so i didn't have to worry about my
nipple hairs nothing it was where's
cockroach guy now
australia that's where he belongs
for some reason it makes sense
that's so true but think about it i
thought australians are are used to
pretty venomous things and scary animals
and living adjacent to them so it might
you know imagine my surprise when he
couldn't handle a cockroach yeah that's
some bit [ __ ] it's not that big of a
deal dude please our first studio that
we had for the podcast had cockroaches
crawling all over it it was so good by
the way i am terrified of cockroaches oh
it doesn't bother me for some reason
they don't bother me at all you know
what you know what annoys me lately is
those big green beetles that fly around
l.a the june the june bugs
i'm not scared of them but they are they
annoy the [ __ ] out of me because they're
slow and i don't want to kill them
they're sweet and you know you just tie
a string to them and then you can
and they hover right i think they're
dumb no
that's why people make tournaments to
pets you could tie a string to them no
but well don't do that guys we don't do
that anymore but when we were kids if
you do send in the video because we
would like to play it on the show yeah
tag us please
donut are you do you have are you scared
of any bugs like spiders or anything
uh
[ __ ] once i moved to california i
mean we had bugs growing up that weren't
like nothing was a big deal in chicago
but like black widows are here brown
[ __ ] recluse are out here i'm like
what
you can die yeah i was in a writer's
room i won't mention her name but a girl
got bit and almost lost her [ __ ] hand
yeah brown recluses are pretty she had
no idea she literally
didn't come for the second week we
thought she was like sick or i mean she
had told people but
she got bit thought it was just a bug
bite the next day her hand was like
all black and blue swollen [ __ ] up she
had to go to the doctor and they said
they almost they were like if you waited
you we might you might have lost your
hand because it [ __ ] up the
circulation do you know are you smiling
do you know who it is no i don't okay
i'm just laughing no but it was a story
but it was insane i was like
that's no yeah so spiders i'm not scared
of them but i'm
mentally haunted by i'm like i don't
want to get bit in the middle of the
night and [ __ ] that's [ __ ] me up
yeah that grosses me out about cow so i
have the spider guy come spray the house
i love this i know
but that's a bummer because they kill
all the other [ __ ] but i just don't
want to get but we have black widows
out of my furniture uh back on the the
deck chairs patios oh that's exactly
where i have them so right in the pool
like la the chase the chasis
lounge
that's where they hang out underneath
underneath you always see their webs and
you can always tell if it's a black
widow because they they cast um low webs
yeah so high spiders usually
non-venomous low spiders
look at that little [ __ ] i mean even
the even the the red crown on it is so
creepy to me yeah like it just tells you
it's like i will
yes it is it's like a [ __ ] marvel
villain oh donut are you with sprinkles
what kind of um what kind of donut would
donut be
i always think of her as a munchkin from
dunkin donuts 100 donut rolls yeah but
what are we talking obviously just the
original uh
i think a cinnamon sugar cinnamon dusted
no well her coat would argue she's she's
original yeah she's just your original
glazed what kind of donuts would you
guys be if you were donuts
um
this is such is one of those questions
that i just need like three days to
think about i'm an old fashioned
oh lucky that's so good my favorite
chocolate they're chocolate glaze and
it's cake doughnut because i i like cake
doughnuts i've always loved cake and my
grandmother used to smoke cigarettes and
eat old fashions and drink coffee and it
was like
embedded in my mind that i am an old
fashioned that's cool that's my donut
it's not that i think i am this donut
it's i would like to be this dog i was
just gonna say i think i wish i was an
apple fritter but i know i'm not you're
not i'm sorry yeah thank you what's
yours can you can you pull up
i love you
pull up um a poi poi poi donut from
liliha's holy [ __ ] so specific i was a
genre you're a
that one and it's mochi inside oh wow so
it's a mochi donut have you ever seen
those you are that of course you're
there go to the picture of it's opened
yeah
below oh yeah wow
so this is what i would like to be
because it looks um it looks pretty um
not exciting from up top right but when
you take it and take a bite there's a
lot more going on so i think i want to
be that you are i think that yeah esther
i think you're
i think you're a long john oh what's a
long john no you're not
it's just
no no no that's esther no you're no
esther's a bear claw no no these are all
the things she absolutely needs oh
chocolate sprinkles okay yeah we just no
i just don't think you want her babe we
haven't finished
regularly no i'm sorry that's not you
either you're you're more you're look
you're something obscure because you are
unique which is good oh you're filled
you're definitely cream-filled
i'm so sorry but you are carlos what are
you
um
he's you know what he is chocolate
chocolate chocolate he's a triple
chocolate doughnut [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying like i went
for the most extreme it's like the most
rich dense sweet over the top over yeah
where you can have one bite and you're
like holy [ __ ] but you know you're gonna
finish it because
you need it don't you just like an
addict yeah you're gonna finish i
shouldn't have all of this i'm gonna
and pete
bear claw europe yeah you're a very
[ __ ]
yeah we haven't found hers but i do know
you're jelly filled
because jelly donuts yeah that's pete oh
my god is that [ __ ] that is
look it's pete
can we do a side by side i bet we
wouldn't know the difference
wait go back to a jelly oh there you go
donut glossary zoom in we can maybe we
can find you in this
esther oh maybe you're like a nut are
you a nut sprinkled doughnut no no no
i'm not into that all right relax oh
cinnamon twist
okay i think you're closer to something
like that
you're definitely i don't know jelly
still keeps coming back yeah jelly i
think you might be a jelly dough okay
fine you know why because jelly donuts
look they look like the other donuts but
they're much more harmful on the inside
like they're way worse for you yeah
that's that's you
you're a bad party animal andrew thank
you so much for joining us i had so much
fun i loved it i'm glad i got to come on
back any time i feel like i should just
be you know what i should just come back
on the show more yeah i like the show
you guys are great i'll tell your fans
if anybody wants to come see me i'm
about to shoot my special
and then i'm done touring for a while
where when denver september 24th
uh at the paramount theater the first
show's almost all totally sold out this
is the second show has some seats left
but i'm warming up in salt lake city
september 9 and 10.
brea i'm doing in southern california
brea wait don't you and bobby have a
show in new york as well we've got two
shows in york where they they sold out
within like six minutes it was crazy it
was actually nuts like we crashed the
ticketmaster site that's awesome it was
[ __ ] like when kylie launched lip
kits same
no it says small it's super small the
grammar sees small it's only a couple
hundred seats so we did two shows it's
500 i know how big it is okay well
they're sold out they they're they're
gone so that one's gone um and then i do
brea minneapolis madison wisconsin and
then i'm done then denver on the 24th me
and bob are trying
trying to do a bad friends tour and
these kids are going to come along for
the ride hopefully if if our agents
don't [ __ ] it up
you know whatever but come see me if
you're in denver september 24th and then
uh
i'll come back on here soon we'll see
you guys next week bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
you